does that come a bit from being born in
Belarus having Russian family Russians
aren't known for complaining much you
know we're not far from Moscow but
they're known for just getting on with
it also you know I'm an immigrant in
this country and I think it gives me an
advantage you were an immigrant in
America does that kind of go hand in
100% I'm writing a book right now I have
three or four books that I'm writing in
my head that's how I write I'm called
I wish everybody was an immigrant it's a
huge advantage you're hungry you get to
appreciate it you know now you're an
immigrant in UK from the US different in
some ways because the u.s. is such a
great you know opportunity place but boy
you know still different you get to see
the UK London market for what all its
value is versus what you had it's
amazing when you go to a different place
very often you went there for a reason
thus you're looking for the opportunity
right you see the opportunities you see
the opportunities here that are
different than what you saw in San Diego
or any parts of the US that's a little
bit again a little bit different most
people come from places that don't have
as many opportunities and they they
can't begin I mean I am not talk to an
immigrant that doesn't have some level
of disdain and or disrespect for every
American they know because they just
know they see it for what it is which is
holy crap there is 87% of the rest of
the world where you'd never have this
chance and probably 0% other place where
it's so rewarded man so rewarded even
with all the immigration and
geopolitical issues at hand still in
America if you come from another place
even though you're stealing our jobs and
all the cliches stuff that the hate and
the negativity that people are pushing
still if you go out and execute and win
America is like you're a winner it's
really you know it's capitalism yeah so
yeah I think it is a humongous advantage
my parents had no gear my mom and dad
had absolutely no no tolerance for
complaining they suffocated it in
hindsight as I sit here and like you can
see I kind of looked over and yeah like
I'm thinking yeah like there was just
like
what are you talking about like there's
just there was no opportunity for that I
really appreciate that it's funny I'm
visceral to complaining and I think it
comes to my parents